hey guys how's it going so today is
Brees big rehearsal dinner our wedding
is this weekend it is extremely exciting
I just realized that I did not edit the
video of me making her wedding cake so
that is currently in process you
probably see that in a few days we're
about to head to our farmhouse and then
do all of the fun little events for the
day but first here's what happened
yesterday
you might notice this luscious glowing
orange skin of mine
oh god my chops can be soaked no I don't
know sometimes about her yeah but I
can't mmm am i coming you told me to
sell me Oh idiot I'm just kidding you're
smart to see you're very smart very
pretty what do you there's a raindrop in
the next 10 seconds I'm sorry I'm gonna
turn down my latte with a extra tribe
event II know that's big one shot
espresso yeah extra chai let's try
Pop's Peter Nelson they come to get
strawberry for nails I'm like a French
manicure but like they look like storm
troopers Cruiser six minutes for each
time I don't even have a single coin on
my person like 36 minutes we're not
looking like his nice big ones in here
oh yeah you can use dawn when I was
going in mmm Rick and I please get
stormtrooper nails and on Vader and kylo
Ren all my jealous one
really I don't care as excited I got the
best manicure that I've ever got in my
entire life but you all never even seen
Star Wars and she did an amazing job
bb-8 now we have drugged Vader right
here this is a r2d2 inspired a
stormtrooper and every here we've got
kylo Ren so beautiful and who got a
pardon to get free guess how much the
ticket is $45 $7 shut up
just you got one yeah
parking tickets in Los Angeles are
likely this would have been like a
hundred yeah cutter pit 75 150
oh girl I paid more in quarters to park
here I want my money own a refund then
all potpourri let's just breathe luck
it's time for spray tan this was really
Shady
well ah the spray channes done I'm a
little concern because she definitely
did it so quick that I don't even think
that I don't I think she missed half my
body she did miss have my body I was
like can you do my armpit she's a woman
really we don't do that I'm like I can't
even I've got to stop this I think we
got too much food it's heavy they land
on I don't know I said you here or what
I love you
he's up inside okay that's good
great fun okay we've only got one
more pickup and we're good all right
here we go everybody's here yay
god I'm so groans always wore Maddy's
pearl it's woods okay let's run away to
Carmel so we'll squad full squad on that
reel
we made it how is it
it's gorgeous you let me walk yeah sure
buddy
I ready going back yo sup hey your
orange is the floor I want to know where
the sun's gonna rise because there
aren't any blind maybe I'll be in this
it's the pig room really nice you just
fire over there like him at I'm playing
Josh for real uh-huh I would also be
playing clash Royale but my game center
won't connect
so I lost all of my progress time fly
the drone at the farmhouse I am so
excited I was actually taking a nap and
I woke up from my nap
Oh
guys I got so many amazing shots I got
this thing so close to the water I
couldn't actually see what I was doing
because it's so bright so I couldn't
really see what I was doing I was
basically just crossing my fingers and
hoping for the best
although behind us turn it this is in
private time I was here I was out here
driving whoa sorry I cut this car off so
I had to really gas it yeah we're on our
way back to the rehearsal
do you gas place I'm not sure what's
going on with mana had a great time
flying my drone earlier he was pretty
cool I was so happy I'm still so happy
about it we made it a little bit late so
we have to act like we're not late the
sign skismo everything's assigned to be
nice you may have seen my post or
Frances's post little Gizzi I know he
was a sweet little boy went up through
so much it was a nice er thanks for
being his buddy online you guys it was
Maddie's first friends he taught him how
to eyes you talking about I'm not a walk
on a leash cuz Maddie would not walk on
a leash together when you adopted it
yeah yeah it was a beautiful thing
alright P gizmo hashtag make sure he's
the hashtag on Twitter well I was wrong
then right now hey Tash Rendon it was so
sweet not only was the outpouring of
love and I know from you guys and then
some other yeah and gizmo
been sold nice like to feel loved and
supported oh he was my little fur baby
for 12 years
we love you Gizzi love you guys mom
thank you madam I don't know my dog's
who's excited for breeze this is the
iographer hello the feature film okay
that field of view is crazy it's pretty
light - I literally might need to copy
this goes 10 to 16 20 - it's good yeah
no zoom is good it's like just enough
you know first carry guess what I've got
in here
I gotta get this lump set alright this
is happening now you guys ready for this
guys might have a problem
thanks for the selection right now
dammit I just got it I got such great
shots
it is abaddon good nearest way boss this
yes we go it doesn't appreciate being
off till tea I lost it I gave you advice
Jenna's gonna be still mad that's her SD
card no let's see what we've got going
on here it's up there I was flying it so
far what happened I was flying it really
hot and the problem is the way that I
was flying it is reversed in the screen
so I went this way and it no you're not
coming back it's your wedding you're not
very smart you know how much I love
climbing turn yellow
I could totally climb that I could
totally climb back do that seriously
like close proximity it's a good
climbing tree will you give me a boost
I gotta film you Bri I was here
you're getting married tomorrow you get
her to go out climbing this frickin
trees I swear what goes there
you gotta value that
what's not that sleazy no one is
climbing this tree bring it
do you really actually excellent that's
a lot hi
that's her hiding the crown of Shuster
on the Tampa Bay Lightning defense when
I went something to do instead of just
sitting around I think tonight was gonna
be really boring but now it's not well
here was talking about the crusher I got
to write my speech you can clearly see
the tree with your eyes yes
but here's the thing I was looking down
and it was off of it you can clearly see
the dream with your eyes I actually
can't see the dryn but when it's coming
towards you it's little opposite so I
had to be turning this way look look you
guys can't even see the drone how can we
expect you'll see to have seen the tree
good this is gonna work - we can shake
in poor direction Matt you better make
sure those people down the other side we
got to Mary wait anybody here play
football out of my shoulders well Matt's
never used to shoulder so we're cooking
all-star second baseman for about seven
years way I don't see it
yeah keep looking it's why don't you
climb the tree that's dangerous
that's really high oh well now yeah
watch this dome known for your safety
yeah but not a breeze wedding Brie's
wedding we can't have any accidents but
we have the only three things that we
need I got a football stuff that you and
I got it out with nothing after
the first throw it's gone it's going
down like the side of the mountain
okay well then hold up I think there's
an opening JB if you go over this way
cuz Matt was throwing rocks so I think
there's an opening you guys can't see
what's happening right now but things
are happening Oh Oh God let in work so
you got these for your brides or you
know bridesmaids but your groomsmen you
and you got the frost - these are so
goaltender Omega boards your climb a
tree know has nothing to do with the
drone it's for fun it's a nighttime game
Obon no no no no no forks
get down this is really was actually the
worst idea ever
I'm so upset like he's going to get hurt
Bart swings you down I don't like this
at all it wasn't trying to help no one's
gonna be under the tree to help make you
fall well Eddie's gonna grab the drones
don't worry no don't try to guess his
own that's also dangerous fine he's been
drinking them forks please don't climb
any higher no no higher Breanna Brian
are getting married tomorrow
Justin come all thank you okay it's
actually a really bad idea I'm very
upset
please stop it looks that can you be
with the camera this is a bad idea
this is so dangerous the drone is a I
know now I got about the drone
why is that me telling why somebody's
here
now you almost got it though yeah do you
think you know I test me we've been out
here for like four hours do you think
you'll be able to get down
poultry no I hate him you got you're
gonna be cooking up less often and it's
making me very uncomfortable
yes dangerous I don't like it I can I
give you a part of this you know it's my
fault
just as the Sarai's dogs to show